entrée
bonjour c'est où je vous en prie alors
madame du serbe c'est ça oui c'est ça
pourquoi vous voulez me voir
bah en fait voilà on vient parce que
avec mon frère on vient de recevoir le
bulletin des bulletins a le le bulletin
de salaire de notre mère
adacore vous savez elle est pas bien
méchant d'autres mamans mais bon et cela
bon là c'est gênant ballon passe ici si
j'aime
ok ces gens ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qu'elle est pas méga au fait de
comment se passe le travail en
entreprise
je me trompe faut la voir à l'oeuvre
pour le business pour doctor qui est
chaud pour le présenter à l'oral this
boy
je veux revenir non
oui
am était marié te vois tu es tu visible
tiens une autre délégué du personnel est
venu se plaindre que vous y aviez mis
une béquille ainsi qu'une frite la cave
c'est vraiment injuste bull votre
délégué s'est vu que même à traiter
monsieur c'est vrai que tim cook and its
bonne maman
bon alors on fait quoi pour ma mère l'a
écoutée bulletins de vote vers l est pas
si mauvais que ça 1450 euros brut par
mois
c'est la moyenne sérieux mais oui
sérieux enfin le pour ce genre de poste
en france oui allez vous prenez pas la
tête c'est pas mon buzz éléments votre
maman avec un petit peu de persévérance
peut-être qu'à la rentrée prochaine elle
passera au troisième
bon très bien bas merci nous avoir reçu
un monsieur bouchez mais de rien dire au
revoir toi la misère n'oubliez pas à
nyon bilan sur le mois de novembre 2011
au nom de mais on a déjà le dos si carlo
harangue quartier de vous plaindre du
cerf et ma petite lucie couché pas trop
tard ce soir demain y'a travail
les mamans qui nous attendent également
oui c'est bon à servas quoi toujours
j'ai rien fait moi